i've talked a bunch about the drake
equation or our own version of the drake
equation that starts with the with the
number of stars in the galaxy but i
haven't given it a shot yet i haven't
tried my own attempt at thinking about
how many detectable civilizations there
are so let's actually do that here
so let's just assume
let's just assume that there are 100
billion stars
100 billion stars so that's my first
term right over there
let's say that one-fourth
let's say that one-fourth will develop
planets
will develop planets and let's say of
the solar systems that develop planets
on average
on average let's say that
point
that they develop an average of 0.1
planets capable of sustaining life or
really that you'll have one planet for
every 10 of these solar systems with
planets that's just my assumption there
i don't know if that's right
now let's multiply that times the
fraction of these planets capable of
sustaining life that actually will get
life and i don't know what that is but i
hinted in previous videos that life is
one of those things that it seems like
if you have all the right ingredients
it's so robust that you have life at
these underwater volcanoes you have
bacteria that can process all sorts of
weird things so let's say that that
probability is pretty high let's say
that that is
50 percent or or half of the planets
that are capable of getting life
actually do have life i would guess that
that might even be higher but once again
just a guess
now we have to think about of the life
what fraction becomes intelligent what
becomes intelligent over some point in
the history well i'll say it's a tenth
a tenth of all you know maybe if the
asteroids didn't kill the dinosaurs it
wouldn't have happened on earth who
knows
or maybe we'd just have some very
intelligent dinosaurs around we don't
know
so and maybe there's other forms of
intelligent life even on our own planet
that we haven't fully appreciated
dolphins are a good uh are a good
candidate some people believe that uh
octopuses have the because they have
such flexible arms
there's a theory that they could develop
eventually the ability to kind of one
day if they if their brains mature and
all of the rest make tools the same way
primitive primates eventually were able
to uh have larger brain sizes and
actually manipulate things to make tools
so who knows i don't want to get into
all of that so there's a 1 in 10 chance
that you get intelligent life
and then assuming that intelligent life
shows up what fraction is going to
become detectable
i don't know i don't know whether
dolphins will ever communicate via radio
or not so let's just say that that is i
don't know let's say that that is
another
another one in 10 chance or i'll say 0.1
0.1 and then we have to multiply it
times the detectable life of the
civilization on average
once again huge assumptions being here
but the detectable life of a
civilization let me just put it at ten
thousand years
ten thousand years either they destroy
themselves or they get beyond that type
of radio type communication
electromagnetic type communication maybe
they start doing all sorts of weird
wacky things
probably won't take you ten thousand
years to even progress it that might
take you less time but let's just do
this just for the sake of fun and then
the lifespan of your average star that's
probably one of the things that we have
the best sense of so on average let's
put it at 10 billion years
10 billion years so let's calculate all
of this let's get my handy ti-85 out and
so we're going to have a hundred billion
that's one times 10 to the ninth
sorry that's not one that's a hundred
times ten to the ninth so let me clear
it or you could have one times ten to
the eleventh
that is a hundred billion times 0.25
times 0.1 times 0.1
times 0.5 times 0.5 times 0.1 again
times 0.1
times point one again
times point one
times ten thousand divided by ten
billion
so times
ten thousand one two three
divided by 10 billion so that's 1 e
1 times 10 to the 10th power 1 with 10
zeros so let's see what we get
we get 12.5 which is kind of a neat
number but you know these are heavily
dependent on this so i'm we're saying if
we given these assumptions there should
be 12.5
detectable civilizations
detectable civilizations in our in our
galaxy right now so the question is
why aren't we detecting it maybe their
radio signals maybe their
electromagnetic waves are getting to us
but we don't we can't differentiate it
from noise right now that's what the
whole seti project's all about of trying
to try to keep track of all of this
information that that all of this these
radio waves and electromagnetic waves
that are coming from outer space towards
earth
and seeing if any of them actually have
any non-noise signal that actually look
like they're being generated by some
type of intelligent civilization so
maybe we're getting them and we're just
not detecting them or maybe something
else is at play maybe we've
overestimated one of these maybe there
is a lot of life but maybe they're not
using electromagnetic waves to
communicate maybe that's some type of
primitive way of communicating maybe
they start doing telepathy or something
crazy or they start using some type of
quantum thing that allows them to
communicate more directly without having
to wait for the speed of light you know
that is a very slow way to communicate
and it is a slow wave frankly if you're
trying to communicate across solar
systems and stars and planets or even
across galaxies one can imagine so maybe
maybe we're just kind of in a transition
state of communication that
electromagnetic waves radio and all the
rest is just a transition state maybe in
a hundred years we'll figure out another
better way that's not detectable in our
traditional ways maybe we're being
bombarded with another type of
communication mechanism that we're just
not ready to perceive yet who knows but
it's just a fun thought experiment to
say that hey given these assumptions
there should be at least a couple of
civilizations or a handful of
civilizations that we might be able to
detect